you
Sebastian Thrun welcome to Udacity talks
we have a really exciting guess a person
who has a life not dissimilar for my own
Anand Adam Allen from Stanford
University a venture capital investor
and a were you called serial
entrepreneur welcome oh thank you
Sebastian nice to be here it's great
having our show
Anand sold the very first company to
Amazon called jungly agus that's right
this was back in 1998 and then even so
the company to Walmart the other guys
mm-hmm recently you also started three
venture funds right that's right this is
C and wishes Val vaca chip many ways and
in 2000 cambree inventor that's right
yeah CAS University invested in Facebook
early on that's right yeah and then you
also teach at Central University data
science data mining data mining that's
great you do a lot of stuff you know I
tried you know diminutive so you born
raised in India that's right yes and
then at some point you came over the
United States how did I have so I did my
undergrad in India at the Indian
Institute of Technology in Madras in
computer science a good one and I
graduated in 93 and then I came over to
the US to I got accepted at Stanford for
you into the ph.d program in computer
science so I came to Stanford to go to
grad school and get my PhD in computer
science I would say it's extremely rare
that students who get it in India gets
admitted straight into the PhD at
Stanford and I know this because I sit
on the admissions committee were set on
the admissions committee for many many
years so congratulations oh thank you
anyway well it was after my time clearly
but still you know I say it fairly
fairly that but not not unprecedented
there have been others a few others Greg
or me and after me so I here next to you
in your office was a Russian guy oh yeah
well I guess he came from Russia when he
was very young yeah I see me talking
about Sergei brain correct right yes
Sergei and I entered Stanford in the
same year in 93 and we you know the in
those days you know Stanford computer
science today is in a building called
the gates building and on the on
Stanford campus in don't you weren't
you're we learned we'd used to be in a
place called Margaret Jack's halls of
barracks
building server barracks that's right if
they used to be in a place called
Margaret Jack's Hall we just kind of
dark building on in the main quad I mean
it had no windows I don't think it was
kind of a dark building on the main I
mean quadrant and right at the top floor
of the building the force world is
building they had an extremely dark area
which with a lot of cubicles which they
call the zoo and that's where they put
the first-year grad students I see who
had just been admitted who did not yet
we have an affiliation with an advisor
once you get the familiar with an
advisor then you can get an office which
is slightly nicer it's still dark but at
least it's an office but you work your
way up and still no witness I suppose
that's right so so it's this this area
that is called the zoo which is really
initial the the the entering grad
students were kept so again and I hacked
you because next to each other it is
nice we were nearby cages and then both
of you became entrepreneurs right so you
said some of the websites named
google.com
and we said angry did you ever consider
joining Google or try to recruit so good
for you you know I always really it's uh
get brilliant guy who's very obvious
it's okay it's brilliant and and when we
were starting our changi we did talk
about it but he I think he was always
talking about Google at the time and
then when we actually styles so we
actually started jungly and I dropped
out I took a leave of absence from the
ph.d program in 96 to start jungly and
Sergey didn't leave till I think 98 97
or 98 so I so I so my group left a bit
earlier just to start gently and Ferris
is shopping and oh yeah that's right so
we read it we pretty much created this
the space of online comparison shopping
although there was not the initial
intention initially we wanted to you
know the origin of that is quite
interesting because initially this grew
out of the research work we were doing
at Stanford at Stanford the the research
the work that I was doing and I was
working closely my adviser was Jeff
almond and we were working on this area
called data integration
the idea that you had data from multiple
sources you're integrated and provide a
commonly used for that people could do
interesting things with the data which
is still a relevant problem today back
in the day we were of could it was this
sort of the research project started
before there was a worldwide that you
know the and and so then the world wide
web came along and it became very clear
to a bunch of us that the most
interesting data was out on the web not
in corporate databases anymore and so we
wanted a new data integration between do
it wanted to do it on the web and we
figured out the best way to do it was
not to do it as a research project but
you do it as a company which was why we
left and we started the the company
Changi we wanted to build virtual
databases on using data from the web and
it turned out that shopping data was
particularly interesting kind of data so
we ended up doing online comparison
shopping as our application interesting
so tell me how did you grow the company
and what happened minion sold it that's
right so so so when we first had this
idea that we that we wanted to do this
on an comparison-shopping there would be
there were four of us were students at
at Stanford grad students at the time
and a couple were close to graduation
I was not and so I actually had to
decide to leave the it's about the
company which is considered fairly
common these days wasn't very common
back back in the day so there was a lot
of angst about that and actually a few
faculty members told me what a bad idea
it was to do and you know how I was
going to regret it
but fortunately Jeff Ullman my adviser
really supported me he said look if you
really believe this go out and make it
happen in the real world you know and
you can always come back and write your
thesis whenever you want and you can get
your PhD so he's very supportive about
that and which was part of you know the
reason that I was able to leave with
this group and and and start the company
so we if the first thing we had to do
was we had this idea that there's
interesting information on the on the
web and we wanted to integrate it and do
in unified views but we had to actually
find concrete use cases to do that and
the first concrete use case that we
thought would be interesting was job
listings
we wanted to disrupt the classifieds
industry and you know they were jobless
things you know the simplest onion get
popular they were job these things on
every company's website so we thought we
could you know jobless things add
structure to them create a unified
database of job listings that's
searchable by location by you know job
title by origins and and sort of create
searchable classified ad but which did
not exist at the time so we did this and
and in fact we we talked to a lot of
newspaper companies most of them are
terrified about what they were doing
because we thought they thought we would
kill our livelihood this actually
happened to them much later but but they
you know they could see it happening
even then and but there was one
newspaper company The Washington Post
Company which thought that what we were
doing was very cool and so they actually
invested in our in our company so we
remember we were four students mustard
is very hard for us to find investments
back in those days those days and like
now venture capitalists and Sand Hill
Road did not want to invest in companies
started by for sure and they wanted to
see faculty members involved they wanted
to see things like that and you know so
so turnt yeah the world is very
different now than it was then was then
so but the Washington Post actually
invested in us and also became a first
customer or nice company and I'm so we
and then with the funding that we raised
we were able to create an online
classifieds application integrating job
listings from all over the web and we
were able to deploy it on pretty much
all the major newspapers websites in the
in the US and that was a first in a
business and then we once that started
taking off we were always attracted
towards shopping and Amazon had just
gone public and there were a couple of
other you know a few other online
shopping destinations in started to
cover there was a critical mass of
shopping data so we thought well now
it's a good time to do online comparison
shopping so that's the second one we
launched and that really took off like a
rocket was deployed everywhere
we had deals the distribution deal with
AOL and
who and various other places for our
line comparison shopping so once that
started taking off we were approached by
by Jeff Bezos who you serve wasn't as
well-known as yesterday obviously oh
yeah that's right a few billion dollars
will do that to you I think but yes he
was he wasn't as well-known then but you
know when in those days in remember
Amazon was had just gone public they
were still selling selling books they
only thing would buy an amazon.com most
books back in I remember this vividly we
had the debate at home and let's say I
was a bad idea and you've come bought us
the bookstore I can look at the book
before I buy it and it can take it with
me right away I was convinced it was a
bad idea that's right but the the but
the but the fact that you missed that
that Jeff saw was that you could have a
much bigger selection online than you
could have in these Indies which makes
my decision even harder I thought right
exactly and and this is I think the very
interesting thing is that sometimes when
you have a lot of data and you and you
can sort of go virtual if you can
disrupt rather than optimize and he
ended up disrupt this big time still
insulate so which is which is which is
what ended up ended up happening and so
so Jeff's division even though he was
only selling books at the time back in
98 was to be the the shop we could you
know find and buy everything online
infinite selection have all the products
in the world right
and he called unified universal products
or something like this I believe and and
he said and he was smart enough to
realize that if if people had to find
every product on Amazon that it's
impossible for Amazon actually
physically carry every product so so
Amazon has to be able to integrate data
from lots of merchants and and make it
searchable and he thought that the
technology that we were building at
jungly was was the appropriate ecology
for us and that's nice that you know
that's why he approached us and the the
amazon acquired jungly back in in 98
quite possibly a year at amazon you've
worked on mechanical truck well i did
that well
Mechanical Turk I did play a role in
mechanical tug but it happened actually
after my time at Amazon interestingly
enough so I spent two years at Amazon 98
to 2000 and helped launch the
marketplace program at Amazon I was
among many people who worked on that and
I left have a son in 2000 and came back
I did two things I came back to Stanford
and wrote on my thesis and got my PhD
but at the same time I also started a
venture capital firm called Cambrian
ventures with one of my co-founders from
young living key and one of the ideas
that we were incubated so during the day
you investing the night you write your
thesis that's about something along
these lines look at the nice thing would
being a VCS that you have a lot more
spare time than Ben you're an
entrepreneur right that's true I see a
lot of VC bicycling in the mountains
here yeah it's the bicycling playing
golf I was writing my thesis and Jesus
writing is a new golf this is right
that's right yeah it's great and then as
an investment crush we soo invested in
this company called Facebook and you
were one of the early investor s that's
right how come how do you meet
Zuckerberg how do you could have well
this is an interesting story you know
it's because we we've you know the this
was back there when we were you know we
could see it sort of I was teaching on
campus at the time and it was clear that
people are starting to use use Facebook
with on campus and then there was a
panel at Stanford on entrepreneurship or
something like this and my partner Venky
was was invited to be one of the
panelists and the one of the other
panelists was Mark Zuckerberg and we got
there and the room was overflowing and
everybody was just asking questions to
mark all the students were there and it
was they obvious that if you know that
Mark Zuckerberg was this kind of hero to
all these students and they were all
using his product and I'm say the
obvious to us that this thing was
catching fire right so we had very early
indications that some data so we really
had dated a mining problem we really
have a like that this thing was taking
off and then it so happened that Mark
Zuckerberg wanted to raise money and he
had to make a he had two offers from
investors who are willing to invest in
us
me one was from this venture capital
from called Excel and the other very
well infirm yes the other is from the
Washington Post company they both were
willing to invest in in in Facebook and
Mark had to decide whose money to take
so he wanted to talk to somebody who had
taken money from both these investors
and in fact there's only one company
that's taken investment from the
Washington Post company that was jungly
and so he he came and talked to us and
and got her opinion on innovation what
is it like and so we gave us you even be
told him everything but he also told him
you know we really like what you're
doing please let us invest in your
company I see and he was nice enough to
let us invest in it I must have been a
good decision but I think it's the best
investment of of my life without so far
I guess all right but we often do in
these Udacity talks we have our students
ask questions and students are very
curious about what it means to be in
Silicon Valley but your career entails
and whatever the next so I have a list
here phone several hundreds of questions
my team has picked a few the very first
is by Peter Kay hi anims can you please
tell us your insights on Big Data and
its application for solving real-world
problems in the near future
sure you know I this is a very
interesting question because I there's
hardly a field of human endeavor that is
not being affected by data so you know
it's probably easier to pick examples of
fields where data is no not going to
play a major role then it's really much
sorry religions well I think there
that's by design
yes so I think that probably very few
fields another fee but it doesn't play a
role these days I honestly don't know I
think it's hard to think of it right so
pretty much every field of human
endeavor shall we say it whether it's
industry or Sciences humanities or
humanities the data seem to be playing a
major doll so the potential is huge but
I think the interesting question the
interesting point that
you know that I that I think about a lot
and I talk to entrepreneurs about a lot
were sort of you thinking about the
space is that a key question that you
have to decide is whether do you want to
use big data to optimize an existing
business with plenty of opportunities to
do that you can make you know my
jennyline scheduling our procurement or
you know what your warehouse management
or whatever it is you can you can pretty
much take anything that's being done now
and optimize it using using big data and
data driven methods or you could take
big data and reinvent whole business and
disrupt it Verizon example they are so
you can think of Amazon is an example of
such a thing Netflix as an example of
what you think uber is an example of
such a thing right so these are all
cases where you have data driven
businesses that have disrupted rather
than optimized like goober didn't sell
software to limousine companies talk to
my dispatch they they sort of disrupted
an industry so I think it's very
important as an entrepreneur to think
about I even use data to optimize an
existing business are you going to sell
software into their business to do that
or are you going to disrupt the industry
class data and I think this is this is a
very important question I think and it
and it sort of it if you choose make the
wrong decision on that it's it's it's
harder to succeed let me ask my person
full of question as an investor which
type company do prefer investing in so
obviously I try to I love to invest in
companies that that I disruptive right
because we create a value they they're
more exciting and they and then end up
creating creating a lot a lot more
investor value along the way so those
are always more exciting to to work with
but you know there are plenty
interesting businesses that that
optimize and and that and that do really
well as well especially from Russell
then you when you come with new ideas do
you actively look for the next big idea
or do you just come over you're gonna
wake up in the morning it's interesting
right I there's a quote that that I you
write which is that fortune favors the
prepared mind so I think if you keep
your mind open and prepared for for new
ideas then you might you might spot them
more more easily it's hard to sort of
think up one
demand but one of the interesting things
I realize is that if you look at all the
people who have achieved great things in
any field of human endeavor you know
great inventors it couldn't be could be
an Einstein or could it could be even a
carl friedrich gauss in mathematics
these are not not all people who did who
did great things but they did great
things because they did a lot of things
and some of them turned out to be crazy
and they didn't even know when they were
doing those things which of those things
would turn out to be great and big
accomplishments and which would be mere
footnotes in history right so you just
have to keep doing a lot of things
almost always to make it like yeah
exactly so you you do many many things
and you keep trying and some things will
become big hits and some things will
become footnotes in history but you
can't tell which ones are going to be
rich it's a question from a gentleman
named Waldo we've asked you actually
sold to companies that would say to the
two extreme ends of the commerce
spectrum when do you think is the right
time to sell your company and what's the
motivation to sell so I'd say the right
time to sell a company is when you get
an offer you can't refuse you know that
that's another way of saying that it's
really hard to to time these things it's
so when I start a company or very when
any entrepreneurs start a company I
always advise them that don't think
about selling night I mean you'll be
always starting a company because we
want to build a great business procedure
you've wanted sort of go public build a
great business you know did you know
change the world that that's what we
want to do and if along the base
somebody comes up with an offer that you
can't refuse
then then by all means you usually you
should take that but then whether it's
an offer that you can't refuse largely
depends on you and your board of
directors at that at that point in time
question four very manual will you
specifically look for any young
developer interesting question right
obviously you you want technical
proficiency and and and all that so I'll
take that as a given and we obviously
evaluate for that in all my companies
but you know once once they are cleared
all those bar
what I personally look for is a sort of
this sort of curiosity and the ability
to always look at everything from first
principles is this something that they
using that that I find so what's a good
interviewing question that space for
first principles you know I I just asked
him you've usually well one of the
simplest things that I do is is that I
ask them to describe to me projects that
they're doing out of personal passion
that they're not doing for work and so
on and they see what the reasoning is
that day that went into it have they
tried to work on something different
that's different from what they're you
know the main you know project was and
if they have what kind of reasoning did
they apply to that and will they make
decisions and in that in that project
because they're your decisions are made
by you not by somebody else so it sort
of interesting to sort of father it's
good to you know Vinita I assume it's an
Indian individual asks the question as
an Indian is it necessary to study in
universities like Stanford or Harvard in
order to be successful and what do you
think is the edge you've got actually
from studying in Stanford so the answer
to this has changed over time right when
I came to Stanford this was 20 years ago
and India was a very different country
20 years ago the world was a very
different place 20 years ago than it has
now
you know now I think lots of people in
India are starting companies straight
out of school like they do here many
graduates from many different
universities and Indian Institute of
Technology the the IIM s are starting
companies and and starting very
successful companies indeed right you're
of India so the so I think these days
you certainly don't need to go to
Stanford or you know leave India to
start start start a successful company
and be successful back in my day there
was less opportunity in India and so I
have you know I did come out Stanford
and then the advantage I got of course
was that I wasn't silicon happen to be
in Silicon Valley yeah it was a network
mm-hm
Peter doesn't question what's the best
way to get venture capital funding for
small project like ten thousand US
dollars and
he asked if he can call you
I actually if you want money like
$10,000 and this is what I always tell
people take money from friends and
family I think those are the people who
know you well and who came back to back
your passion most investors professional
investors want to see some progress
before they invest and they wanna invest
larger amounts of money why how come
that they want to invest large amounts
of money explain this to audience a why
do proportion investors want invest
larger amounts of money well your
typical BC manages a fund of a certain
size let's say couple hundred million
could be some anywhere between let's say
a 100 million to a billion dollars right
off of money we'd save raise from from
from a lot of other limited partners
like pension funds forgiving the money
and a typical VC partnership has a few
few partners now if these partners made
small investments of $10,000 they'd have
to make thousands of investments but
they might be better for risk
diversification portfolio right the
empathy they might be there are two
problems with that huh there's only so
much human time available so evaluating
all these deals and then following up on
them and keeping track of them there's
only so much human bandwidth available -
so you're saying no phone call for
$10,000 yeah I would prefer no phone
call for $10,000 yeah yeah that's
actually it's very common it's common
for the venture capitals it takes
something like 20% in the beginning and
then take a board seat I've made many
ways said if you don't give me 20% I'm
not very well but absolutely one thing
though we actually either the current
one of the the current funds rate and
rocketship dot BC we follow a very
different model of our venture investing
which you know some of some of you are
the people in your audience might find
interesting we use big data and data
driven methods to be to run a VC firm is
completely different from the from the
the traditional VC approach the
questions are get data on the startup
company that's exactly that's a very
good question we live in a world where
we can actually get data on sort of
gonna be built a big database now by
gathering data we have data on a million
startups all over the world and 50,000
of them are trying to raise funding at
any point
in time and so the either about 90% of
them are outside Silicon Valley 10% of
them are in Silicon Valley and we run
algorithms on on all these startups and
find interesting companies that we think
are interesting we look at key we look
at the traction that they are getting in
the market various things and we come up
with the score and we and B reach out to
the companies that we find interesting
so mean to be knows no no company about
pitches us we find interesting company
through our data and we reach out to
them most of these companies are not in
Silicon Valley we investments all over
the world India we have you have
investments in India we have investments
in Europe we have investments in South
America and Canada rest of us right so
Marcos ask you the questions in your
opinion why do you think that some solid
companies fail can you give examples of
failed companies maybe without
mentioning names and explain why they
would fail sure this is an interesting
question right I think you know there's
a famous book called Anna Karenina by
Leo Tolstoy and there's a line in there
that says you know all happy families
are alike each unhappy family is unhappy
in its own way
so I think each startup that fails fails
in its own own way because there are so
many different ways to fail success is
actually it rare right because
everything has to go right for success
happened that's why happy families are
happy because everything goes right
but even if something goes wrong you get
an unhappy family or or a failed failed
startup so there are many ways that the
rest our top can can fail but I'll tell
you a couple of common themes that you
know I find even particularly as an
investor this is the hardest thing to
evaluate is team chemistry you know
sometimes things could be going really
well the markets and create a product
great but the founders don't get along
and the founders don't realize that they
don't get along when they start the
company Yeah right and when they are
raising funding it's only when you're
like two to three years into the company
and you're sort of hitting that first
rough really rough patch
mm-hm and you're going down and you
start yelling at each other that's when
you realize
that that chemistry right and things
things fly apart that's kind of one of
the most unfortunate ways in which
startups can fail and so I always tell
people who ask me for my advice as to
when you start a company make sure you
have a prior working relationship with
the person that you are starting the
company with don't it's always better to
have gone through you know either you
work that student together at also you
know or something like that the same was
true for marriages yeah summers hard
divorces found us in this divorce as a
couple we have a question from
Kazakhstan a student in Kazakhstan Jay
Russell I think is his name and yes this
is okay to build a similar startup in
another country I first I would take a
you as a startup company is working well
and kind of copied the model in launched
it in Kazakhstan no I this time-honored
method of starting startups so far be it
for me to say it's a bad idea I mean if
a lot of people do it and it means that
Amos
three-bath of the Germany who do this
that's right the fam residue in Germany
and clearly there are people copying US
models in in Asia in China in China and
in India
and the other way around these days so
so I think this is a time-honored
tradition so so so it's so it can work
the only thing I would suggest is if
you're gonna do it pick a large enough
market for it to be a viable startup
China is a suddenly large enough market
India is kind of borderline but in years
only 1.3 billion people obviously yeah
but you know India's only 1.3 billion
people but the spending power and the
sort of online population is still not
as large as China's merciful I think
it's getting there though yeah that's
that's the that's interesting that's
interesting piece Kazakhstan I don't
know anything about Kazakhstan to say
whether it's a beginner market or not
but I would probably target a larger
area I can see it start up targeting
like Central Asia or the Middle East or
something like this photographing
interesting interesting it is remarkable
actually if you go say to the iPhone App
Store or the Android app store at the
top rather of 100 or 1000 apps are
mostly built in America
well that's because you're looking at
the US app store I see
but even worldwide if you look at
worldwide was like the top apps are all
in China so we actually tracked this and
see we actually tracked this we have
data on on our apps and how they are
taking on because this is part of our
rocket ship
venture capital firm which is data
driven so we are tracking all the
crop-top apps in the world and ones that
are growing and of the top 1% of mall
apps more than half are from China hmm
so it's it's just a huge population
after ask you are you'd ask a specific
question what do you think is the future
of Education gonna be in countries like
India right well clearly it's it's
bright right so but the exactly why what
form it takes I am Not sure I think I
online learning I think is things like
Udacity I think are are going to be a
big part of it certainly I think there
seems to be a great demand for knowledge
and then improvement and it's hard to
see how that that's gonna be fulfilled
just through traditional universities in
school so I think online learning of
this sort is clearly a huge part of it
but we have probably tens of thousands
of young people although in the world
watching right now when I ask you one
last question before we out of time just
something you want to tell young people
like to yourself if you were like 15
years younger a piece of advice you'd
give yourself at this point yes I you
know I would say you you dream big right
dream big and you believe that you can
change the world we live in a world
where everything is possible right now
and you know so dream big you can change
the world and look at everything from
first principles this is the thing this
is my hardest one learning in life don't
accept the status quo in anything just
look at it from first principles and
judge for yourself
this is exactly what I answer it or me
God things first principles and then
it's been a phenomenal pleasure having
you here at Udacity and Jesse talks
and Raja Rahman who is a serial
entrepreneur sold companies
Amazon and Walmart started three not
just one but two three venture funds
teachers at Stanford and looks 24 years
old as fast thanks for coming oh thank
you for having me
absolute pleasure we co with number six
we're still lining up the right speaker
we have a few potential candidates but
stay tuned and I'm gonna see all of you
again when we talk to the next speaker